I like to say that silence is the think
tank of the soul
listening is something different
listening means taking all sounds in
with equal value
so instead of listening for a sound I
simply listen to the place today it's
the echo of the whole river brush off
the mountain ridge top it is a sound of
the valley and not only the sound of the
valley but where I am in the valley it's
all information yes I record sound and I
record nature but that's just what I
need to do in order to become a better
listener
nature is as busy communicating as we
are I find places that are completely
free of noise pollution in places that
we can listen to nature at her most
natural
[Music]
there is a epidemic of extinction of
quiet places on the planet there is not
one natural place on planet Earth
set aside off-limits to noise pollution
here the auditory horizon can be as
great as 20 miles now if you do the math
and you calculate the area of a circle
with a 20-mile radius that's over a
thousand square miles I come here to be
reminded what an opportunity it is to be
alive today
nature is music and I'm not asking you
to get all theoretical here I'm saying
just listen
[Music]
I've recorded well over 700 different
logs which I now call nature's largest
violin I question whether anything in
nature is really as random as I once
assumed it to be that somehow at some
high level and sometimes small level
it's all math and harmony and wave and
sound
sound has told me
to be like the wave
accommodate all things
we think of ourselves living in this
information age
well the auditory horizon in the city if
we're lucky is only two blocks and
you're lucky if you can even hear the
footsteps of the people around you and
the information is often the same the
repetitive of just a few species I find
that when I'm in the city that I become
very self aware every place I look in
the advertisements and the people in the
fashion and and the conversations all
about people all about us and I find
myself thinking about me so in the city
even when were outside we live in small
worlds
we cannot think truly originally and be
ourselves without quiet and that is the
gift of quiet is that it allows the
faint meanings of sound to gain its
original importance
this is the time to be alive this is
when we will make the big decision will
we or will we not fall back in love with
planet Earth
[Music]